pour en parler en direct avec nous à
dominique pradalié secrétaire générale
du syndicat national des journalistes
bonjour madame pradalier merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france a
voulu revenir avec vous sur l'un des
avocats de julian assange et sur ses
propos la sphère n'est plus juridique
mais politique
est ce que c'est un avis est que vous
partagez bonjour à toutes et tous
bien sûr cela dépasse le cadre juridique
bien sûr des citoyens du monde entier
sont extrêmement attentifs à ce qui est
en train de se passer à old bailey à
londres
c'est un bras de fer entre des
gouvernements et le droit d'informer et
d'être informé
alors justement est-ce que selon vous on
parle assez de cette affaire à ce qu'ils
aient assez de résonance aux tourrades
u15 ulian assange
et bien si jolie anna charges devaient
être d'extrader aux états unis ce serait
un signal catastrophique pour les
journalistes du monde entier
cela voudrait dire que désormais les
gouvernements vont tout faire pour
privilégier la communication donc la
propagande contre le droit à
l'information
alors c'est ça qui bloque dans ce
dossier un c'est julien assange ses
avocats ses partisans le présente comme
un journaliste les américains en tout
cas la justice américaine parle plutôt
d'un espion on en vient aux cas des
journalistes d'investigation est ce que
cette profession cette profession
précise
est-ce qu'on en parle acs qu'elle est
assez protégé en france et dans le monde
entier
aucun journaliste ma connaissance n'a
jamais travaillé sans bénéficier de
fuite
sssa l'accusation qui est lancé contre
julien assange
donc tous les journalistes se sentent
concernés et le fait que la france par
exemple
malgré nos nombreuses demandes ne lui ai
pas encore accordé l'asile politique est
quelque chose qui nous chagrine
énormément et nous arrivons nous avons
fait de nouveau la demande de voir le
nouveau
au garde des sceaux qui comme vous
monsieur dupont moretti qui comme vous
le savez a rejoint une époque le pool
des avocats de français défendant julian
assange on ne parlait effectué par les
de la protection des sources des
journalistes
bien que la france se puisse se targuer
d'avoir une loi assez protectrices
depuis 2010 c'est intéressant mais c'est
un combat que nous avons gagné et qui
permet aux journalistes de protéger
leurs sources et pourquoi la france
particulièrement doit jouer un rôle dans
cette affaire
pour deux raisons la première c'est que
elle a été elle a accordé au journaliste
et à statut juridique d'exception qui
leur donne des possibilités d'avoir une
conscience et d'être indépendant et la
deuxième c'est que bien sûr tout le
monde le sait c'est la patrie des droits
de l'homme
donc la france doit offrir l'asile à
julian assange
alors julien sont justement par le coût
de son état de santé un état de santé
physique psychologique et serait à
dégrader est ce que en tant que
secrétaire général du syndicat national
des journalistes est ce que vous en
savez un peu plus nous savons que notre
confrère
julian assange est soutenue déjà bien
sûr par son syndicat australien tous les
autres syndicats qui craignent
énormément comme nous pour son état de
santé car il est je vous le rappelle
confiné depuis presque 10 ans et au
moment du confinement générale en france
je lui ai envoyé une lettre pour son
anniversaire en dix ans maintenant nous
sommes tous confinés
on verra si c'est aussi dur ou aussi
long pour vous que pour nous et nous
n'avons pas de réponse et même à la
prison d'el menti il a fallu énormément
démarches pour qu'il ne soit sorti de
son isolement
donc je veux dire n'importe qui seraient
en grande difficulté de santé dans des
conditions aussi dures
et aussi inacceptable et aussi peu
normal dans un pays comme la grande
bretagne
madame printanier merci beaucoup d'avoir
été en direct avec nous rappelle que
vous êtes secrétaire général du syndicat
national des journalistes merci